welcome back to Las Vegas now you know
February is Black History Month and in
honoring the black community we also
have to consider and honor the
well-being of the black community
keeping mental health at the Forefront
someone who does that all year round is
the Nisha Mingo CEO of Mingo Health
Solutions welcome to the show thanks so
much for having me oh of course now I
want first and foremost congratulate you
on your success because we're also
honoring black Excellence oh thank you
that's amazing you know we need you in
our communities we've got traumas
whether it's generational personal
second hand watching the news yes so so
much so to explain you know even though
we need you so much it's also still such
a very taboo Concept in the black
community yeah it absolutely is although
we see specific specifically um during
the pandemic that this conversation and
dialogue is opening more it's still very
taboo I see it every day people are
still struggling to ask for help
historically some of those reasons I
have been particularly pertaining to the
black community in the United States uh
many of them are Faith people of Faith
backgrounds and so that means that a lot
of the issues that arise out of mental
health have been seen as spiritual or
demons and they haven't been open to
asking for help additionally there has
been a distrust with the health system
so even learning and understanding about
it has contributed to black people's
willingness to be able to and seek help
and then lastly due to you just got to
name it slavery there has been a sense
of resilience and strength and so
there's this mindset that we can just
deal with and overcome we don't need to
ask for help and talk about it wow okay
and what does Mingo Health Solutions do
to help that
well we do therapy and counseling
services for lifespan that includes
children and adults families couples
a group that's a wonderful
um but we do a lot of Outreach so we we
actually are celebrating our seven year
anniversary in March and our history has
been doing a ton of Outreach to educate
and what we have found is because people
see us out in the community they're
gaining more awareness knowledge
education but then they're already
they're also seeing people who look like
them which makes them more open to
asking for help wow now what are some of
the signs really quick just name maybe
two really important signs to look out
for for your loved ones or for yourself
that might you know indicate that you
need help the first thing is always
going to be any change in behavior that
is an indicator that a crisis has
occurred if people are isolating if
there has been a lack of sleeping or
more sleep and lack of eating those are
some of the basic signs that are crossed
the board for Mental Illness but it does
matter what other symptoms are coupled
with it I'm so see a professional see a
professional and how can people do that
give us your information they can do
that by calling us at 702 848 81696 or
visiting our website
www.mhsbs.com and I do have a non-profit
called Solutions of change that offers
free therapy and counseling for those
who are uninsured underinsured and
undocumented but if you call MHS